this is an accusation that people throw
at you and then is your responsibility
to issue an apology for something you
you've never even encountered in your
life and then to defend yourself and
even we got a lot of messages saying
well now you should donate money to any
of the black life matter causes and that
to me is extortion
[Music]
hi I'm Dave Rubin and it's Small
Business Week here on the Rubin report
joining me today is an a' b oven
co-owner of cuchara restaurant in
Houston Texas and a welcome to the show
I thank you thank you for having me
yeah my pleasure I'm glad to have you
because I wanted to have someone in the
restaurant business because I think you
guys are dealing with some seriously
unique problems so first off just tell
us a little bit about why you started
cuchara how long have you guys been in
business and then you've done some super
interesting things during lockdown to
stay successful so I want to get into
that as well well the restaurant is
gonna be eight years old this September
the concept behind it is every time I go
to Mexico I crave my grandmother's food
my aunts food I don't pray but chef so
that's a concept we have all-female
staff in the kitchen and they're all
moms from Mexico they all do art they
have so much passion and they care for
fresh ingredients and they're crazy for
that so basically they arrived they
recipes without any twist and then they
go home that's the principle that's how
I always want to be an all-female
kitchen to bring really the flavors of
the Mexican food that I grew up with so
that's how it all started our
anniversary September 15 which is
Mexico's independence very not known for
many Americans but that is Mexican
Independence September 15 so if we can
we'll have a big celebration
this year again hopefully all these
Tobit thing will be gone by then
and basically the concept for the
restaurant besides fresh food and emails
is to also bring culture like Mexican
celebrations to Houston so people can
understand and see what Mexico truly is
about during the Kobe 19 of course we
were forced to close our dining room and
patio so we started because people know
that we do lots of different events and
lots of different parties we kind of
wanted to bring those to their home so
we did classes online to play Lotteria
and prepare cocktails to make tamales
along with one of my cooks we did a lot
of different little events for regulars
where we created like an ID on Facebook
so it was private just for them we also
did a YouTube channel so we posted the
tamales class or some other little
things we try to keep people engaged
because we are in the middle of a very
international eclectic neighborhood and
we have a lot of clients the majority
the ones that support us day by day
they're single they come to the
restaurant because they met new people
new friends and they felt that solitude
of not being able to come to us as what
they would use so we try to stay in
touch with them via Facebook or doing
little events with them and creating
different packages for them and learn
how to make rice pudding or a salsa with
a more time we did lots of cute little
events so that people felt engaged and
they could see the other regulars at
least if it wasn't a simple so you
started as a restaurateur and you became
a youtuber in the midst of coronavirus
I didn't really want it but we had and
and how has business been through making
some of these changes you know it was
really challenging but it worked I mean
we we cannot complain our sales were not
as terrible as we thought they would be
in our minds we never wanted anyone to
have to be furlough or for them to have
to go get unemployment we just really
wanted to keep everyone
in our staff we love everyone in our
staff we have 52 employees and I just
you know want to be historic we've been
organized so we didn't have to worry
about it we were able to do payroll even
before the workout so everyone was
grateful and thankful and happy to have
a dog even though it was just a very few
weeks
very few hours per week compared to the
long hours were used to but you know it
worked fine as I said the sales we're
not that disappointing and once we were
allowed to reopen then we started going
up again so I would say it affected us
but not as bad as we thought or as other
fellow researchers yeah are you worried
as a small business owner that even
though you guys survived this one and
you did some some cool fun things to
make it through that you know we could
get a second wave or there could just be
some other thing that that kind of puts
you out again and you know like all
small business owners you don't have a
giant corporation that can kind of keep
you afloat in these rough times correct
yeah we're scared about you know the
city deciding closest again right now
we're dealing with a lot of problems
because of the social distancing some
people tell you one thing some people
tell you another there's really not a
very good communication system with the
government with the rules and
regulations follow which led us to like
another big problem we have they want us
to keep six distance big tables which
we've done so even if we're supposed to
be open except and it doesn't work for
us
because a restaurant is not huge so by
keeping the six feet distance we are
open at 50% capacity when when were very
like full and and happy because of the
distance following all the protests for
George Floyd and whatnot we're social
distance was totally irrelevant my
business partner made a comment of
personal Facebook staying well I guess
the social distancing is
not enforced so the mayor and the police
went to a parade and where nothing was
enforced and we started getting attacked
because he called it a parade instead of
some March which is basically I don't
know just a technicality that didn't
mean anything he could have used another
soccer game anything just to prove that
the government is not helping us with
regulations but these militias person
was tending he's coming to all these
activist rappers and all those people
that are ready calling your racist when
you're not so we started getting these I
guess bombard comments and ugly you know
even death threats and people requesting
that he would give an apology for being
a racist but he's like no I'm not gonna
give in a bully because I'm not a racist
I kept in black friends of ours getting
threats or they are friends these really
truly became crazy way more than the
Kobe nine would have ever hurt us it was
this action of malicious people just
pointing the finger and saying that my
business partner sir racist that he
doesn't like blacks that he doesn't like
Mexicans when we are all Mexican in the
restaurant except for him and just
calling him ugly names like white
supremacist remember when all he did was
use the word parade which was the word
Reverend Lawson referred to in the event
it's a reverend that Lloyd's family
chose to speak and he called it right he
called it a he called it a parade so
actually so I'm glad you transitioned
into that because you know we got we got
hundreds of people that wanted to do
small business we can and obviously lots
of restaurant tours that did some
interesting things but I thought this
part of your story when I read this is
the next level of all of this that you
guys you survived through Co vid you do
what you have to do and then your
business partner makes a completely
absolutely fine statement we can all
debate the word parade or not even
though
you're saying the Reverend at the
funeral actually said the word parade
but putting that aside but now you're
under a different type of attack and
literally thousands of messages and I
saw some of them and and death threats
and and the rest of it in many ways I
think you just sort of alluded to this
do you view this as more of a danger as
a small business person than than the
other stuff definitely because this is
an accusation that people throw at you
and then is your responsibility to issue
an apology for something you never even
encountered in your life and then to
defend yourself and even we got a lot of
messages saying well now you should
donate money to any of the black life
matter causes and that to me is
extortion because we're in no position
to donating anything to anyone but our
employees just surviving but now you
have all this special really weird
interest bugging us to try to make us
donate to specific causes that we don't
we didn't even know existed because as
an in our minds would never be someone
that would be accused of being a racist
or or a discriminator in any way or
manner so it is just frustrating it's
frustrating to see how many people stand
behind our people like that that just
use our keyboard as their weapon they're
in other states they're not even people
from Houston their people from Atlanta
and people from California people from
Troy and from whatever places that have
never probably even been in Texas and
they they're jumpin and a hue source of
being racist when we we're not you and
your business partner are standing up
for it and I promise you you know I was
supposed to be on a book tour and how to
stop in Houston so when we reschedule it
I will definitely have dinner with you
guys
and now just to close out if I'm going
to the restaurant in Houston what am I
having for dinner planned me the perfect
meal tell me the perfect meal now I know
there's gonna be a margarita there give
me what's the perfect meal
that I would be having you're going to
start with a fresh my god all our
ingredients are fresh every single day
we don't face anything so every whatever
it's not amazing but I would definitely
make you fry crispy potato tacos which
becoming a very spicy salsa that is very
hard to make even though it looks simple
do that test to the flavor you'll
probably have the pork tenderloin with
Molly or black or green Molly's my
favorite it's my grandma's recipe and I
think that's besides the bestseller
that's my favorite thing in the menu you
probably will try a few sides like the
shape corn or the corn curious and then
at the sir we have many different
desserts and I would recommend this in
collections because it why think oh
right I've never heard of Cinco I know
there was trace I did not know that was
even possible it was fully love it's
delicious Wow
two extra Lachaise okay all right well
Anna thank you so much it's cuchara
restaurant in Houston Texas I wish you
guys a lot of luck and don't worry I
promise you if I know one thing you will
survive the mob and you guys will come
out better on the other side thank you
so much if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell